congratulations on genre just dropped
yesterday
how are you feeling that this album has
been released and you can finally share
it uh with your fans um i'm feeling
great you know it's it's a big relief
it's like i've had these babies for so
long and now i'm like here you're 18 now
go do your own
yeah so it feels great it feels like a
relief
i'm so happy that people get to hear it
yeah amazing how does this collection of
music differ from the music that you've
put out with the rose
um definitely different style different
genre of music i think um and with the
rose right we write uh we have four
brains working on the song yeah this is
mostly one brain so i think it's just
most it's more personal i could say
yeah yeah that makes sense well beyond
performing these tracks you also you
know we're really heavily involved of
all the aspects of the creative process
of it all from writing to composing to
arranging why is that so important
to you
because i think like for me um
my solo projects are like a healing
process for myself as well yes we are
making music so other people could
listen and they could feel certain
things and that's great too but like i
think as as i go on with the process it
heals me in in a different way
than just listening to someone else's
music so i think that's why i'm so
involved in
you know little details and everything
yeah it's it's a it's a good therapy
session for me every time oh for sure
now some of these songs were written a
while ago has your relationship with
these songs changed over time like do
you see them or sing them differently
now
i think yes and no i think from the
beginning i especially with the
with like temples right that was one of
the most that was one of the first ones
that i wrote um
uh like four or five years ago when my
first ep came out wolf um but yeah i
think as it grew on me more
um you know became i became so attached
and i feel like i'm so biased
towards it now
um but other than that like the song
direction or
uh where where where i saw like how it
was gonna end blah blah blah that was
all pretty similar from the beginning
very good
is there one song on the album one track
on the album that that you are
particularly proud of and and why would
that be
i i'm proud of hangover that's number
one it is the number one track uh it's
the intro track but i'm proud of it
because now every time i have a hangover
i have something to listen to
[Music]
of my mistakes
and then yeah it just this just
normalizes my hangovers a little bit
more
i mean that's a good thing i i feel like
any time you can normalize it it's a
good thing
fans are just getting uh new music
they're also getting to hear more about
you know quite frankly your life and
your journey as part of the series on
mindset by drive studios what compelled
you to share your story
uh in depth this way
um i think i think it was
i never really had somewhere to really
um talk about my personal
um you know just my my personal stuff
growing up like who i truly am i think
once
they get to know who i am really it
would kind of i think we could connect
better and we could really understand
each other better in that way um and it
will make more sense as of like how i
wrote this music or why i wrote a
certain song you know because i i can't
really say they're always 100 just
my story you know i'm here trying to
create for other people
certain
certain wordings and certain stories
that i want to tell that is not
necessarily my own story and with that
if you know the
narrator
more personally i think it makes more
sense it gives it a good
experience for everybody definitely um
growing up in the united states you know
wanting to play football and then to
pursuing a career as an entertainer in
korea
you have to have a lot of drive and
determination to do that who has been
your person that has been inspiring you
and kind of being there with you
throughout this journey
um i i mean myself
[Music]
i think that was the most important i i
always had to check myself and really
understand myself
okay to go through this process because
i i felt like in the middle of my
journey i'm still in it yes but like
growing up as a young adult when i just
became an adult i think
if i didn't know myself and if i didn't
know how to heal myself
no one else could
um yeah
you know that's that's very deep and
that that usually takes a lifetime for
people to figure out the fact that
you've figured that out already is so
huge
i'm still in the process of finalizing
it
right yeah no for sure well in in the
teen vogue interview you mentioned that
you have a love-hate relationship with
music because of what have you
experienced throughout your career are
you still learning to deal
to deal with the pressure of the music
industry and being an idol
no for sure i think at the end of the
day no matter what you love there's
always gonna be pros and cons okay yes
it's never just like a perfect i love
this and it's just this it's there's
always gives uh give and takes and for
music it's always going to be like that
and i accepted the fact that we have a
love hate relationship i think uh
because i love it so much i also can
hate it so much as well because i'm
spending most of my time
with music yeah and they say that the
the degrees of separation between love
and hate are actually very close right
yeah for sure
um more and more k-pop stars are coming
out uh and stars in general people in
general are coming out and talking about
their mental health
very openly um and you've been very open
and honest about your struggles why was
that important for you to do that
i think it's very important not just for
me but for
everybody that has emotions
which we all do right i think it's good
to heal those emotions we only have one
life yeah and we don't want to be stuck
in this one state of mind and not get to
enjoy
all this love and energy in this world i
think it's such a waste if we don't get
to fully enjoy it because we don't have
a long life so i think um once you
really get to figure yourself out and
everybody's different right nothing's
right or wrong when it comes to emotions
and personalized feelings so once you
get to really get to know yourself and
you could kind of bring out the best of
yourself
it's it's you know it doesn't matter if
you do music if you're a journalist if
you're in
uh if you're a doctor
whatever job you may have
it's just you know that one thing isn't
everything about you there's so much
more to
one person and it's so different that um
you know it's just kind of like enjoy
the process and if you want to enjoy it
you have to heal yourself and know how
to enjoy it right you've mentioned a
couple times in this interview healing
healing yourself
and i i have to ask because i think
you know people come to learn about that
and the importance of healing past
traumas or healing generational things
that go on
yeah who who introduced you to that idea
is that something that you happened upon
yourself or is there someone in your
family who has led you to be so help you
be so introspective because i you know
i've talked to
lots of people in my in my career and
not a lot of people
get to that point
no for sure and i and i think um
i can't really say who
or what
i think it was more of realizing that i
want to heal myself and um and there's a
lot of people that do help me realize
that uh next to me
my family
my friends
um the people i work with but it's
always uh
yeah it's not one person it's not one
situation but it's like accepting the
fact that
there's some healing to do because we
all have traumas right yeah and and the
and this one advice i got recently was
very good for me was um
this person told me you had you feel
everything there's all these little
things you feel and some some something
little might agitate you and it's going
to start building up right so when it
does
take that and break it apart like see
what it is like exactly one by one and
where it started and i started doing
that in my head and it's been helping me
a lot too um
yeah i can't say you know i know the
exact way i know you know this is right
this is wrong but for me i'm figuring
out what works for me as i go that's
amazing you're paying attention that's
that's really good um we know that your
group the rose is no longer under
contract with jay and star company and
that you released your solo material
under your own label now do you think
fans can expect the gree the group to
reunite and release
new music through your label
um
we are talking about you know different
options we have so many options with the
rose i think um and we don't want to
force anything and and i don't to be
honest i don't want it to be under my
own company because the roses of is like
ours it's not just my thing it's our and
i i want it to be fair for each member
um
and i want them to be involved as much
as
like they can it's always a 25 25 25 25
you know what i mean so
no way it doesn't have to be under my
company it doesn't have to be under any
company it doesn't you know we're trying
to figure all that out but definitely
look look out for new music because we
are working on that
so next year
next year so okay so hajjun is gonna be
so my drummer hajini he's gonna be the
last
one coming out of the army which will be
around july
okay yes next year's july okay good to
know
um you have some great collabs on genre
um are there any north american artists
that you would like to work with in the
future oh so many so many um
i mean i've mentioned this a bunch of
times like laney lau they're all great
artists uh
let's see
just like even djs right i think sure
yeah djs i've been really getting into
like um
electric music as well so i think um
yeah that could be a vibe so many all
these opportunities and all these well
whoever
i think it's just like whoever's there
and the vibe yeah
that's amazing well congratulations on
everything we're really excited to see
where you go and what you do next thank
you